[Music]
getting close to landing and
in New York
just uh finally got a little sleep on
this flight
then true
New York City
one hour sleep in London in 24 hours I
was it was a little tough so knotted for
successfully hours I've been pounding on
my emails something interesting I've
been thinking about thought I would
share right now which is the notion of
not doing email
when you're actually at home base it's
funny how little email help or actual do
work
what I would call defensive work
responding to things that are second or
third or fourth or fifth cure priority
just to get them done I tend to save
those with the use of my assistant Tyler
for
for moments like this where I have
downtime on the flight it's interesting
to me that it takes some a long flight
for me to really catch up with something
that I think a lot of people prioritize
so sort of fun track to figure that I'm
going daily share some of like the small
little tactics that have allowed me to
scale what people ask for the details if
in one of the details is categorizing
what's actually important
has to be done right away and pushing
the things that are not as important
further down the line so that when
you're in your day to day you're able to
actually have the meetings and interact
with the people that are actually
driving your business and there's a huge
lack of understanding that spec meetings
bizdev meetings HR meetings
they get pushed by
you know what's that meaning we really
you know why I'm taking this potentially
good meeting with you best things to do
or let HR handle that when people are
your most important asset or there's
only do a favor for a friend who is a
real friend or a real business partner
just think that people don't prioritize
a lot of those things when there are the
actual things you should be doing itself
and then when you actually have downtime
like on this flight on this flight I'm
not meeting anybody except maybe my crew
here and so that's what I should be
getting to the things that I think a lot
of other private people prioritizes it
we gotta get this done
I can wait two or three days and so
just going to play now about the land
the intermediate office have two
important
employee meetings around some business
opportunities that I'm going to be with
a potentially our first major sports
draft class 2017 signing
next game and listen the Sun repeat for
the last four hours
no sweat up no minutes like gonna good
enough so you gotta be great and I'm
gonna do whatever it takes giving you my
heart every take play fill to the top
one step of my big hands to the right
away gotta go get it if you want it I'm
still trying to figure out how pop so
he's asking what's gonna happen when I
ain't here you being a man at a house so
I gotta grow up every day since applause
and so right now should I pay these
bills but if I was working on the five
like seven days a week one of the great
wastes of time in my life right now
reviewing dailyvees to make sure one
little thing doesn't slip in that might
be a comms issue or leak something or
hurt somebody or hurt something or
offend someone or stir the pot too much
hate it all right
hate it I like the window but feel like
I'm a dog ice global warming is real no
windows open December 2nd in 1984
100 we're going okay cool
alright I'll say a little bit today's
gonna be a big day this is this is my
daily be is so awesome we are signing
our first player of the 2017 draft class
and the timing that AJ and I bought into
and bought cemetry sports this is you
know Vernon and bunch other guys who
Sadat last year but we kind of inherited
that process this was our first
coast-to-coast process this is kind of
like in a really exciting love this with
our first player we're signing as a
complete Vayner sports entity I met I
met jaylen and in a Tennessee when I was
in Chattanooga were you with me that
thing now this is exciting for me it's a
big big moment look how good the New
York looks dry
porphyria wrong it's a good-lookin wall
bang [ __ ]
something good happen that's [ __ ]
awesome
why you keep me guys around I just
landed from London I'm walking into the
vaynermedia office just living the dream
I am hi great hold on one second what's
that
sure what's your name Bianca Gary like I
started following you on Instagram Risa
thank you very inspirational do you work
here I do I work at coach where are you
guys going they know media that's my
company we work here too I'll probably
see you again have a good weekend
nice to meet you hey no no no no I just
love human beings just like I'm a human
being lover you you like them I'm gonna
put them on right now that sub right
yeah I just in London five minutes ago
yeah what
you got you need me for two seconds okay
okay fine fine
what about before that it won't go and I
feel like it's cuz I have drafts until
I'm done with the drafts would that be
possible
I don't think so cuz I thought I got
some off hey guys
that's my intuition you know what I mean
you got two seconds cuz I know I'm not
gonna catch it before the end of the
year yeah I'll have a two seconds go
hang around there I'll be back what's
going on hey Paul such a pleasure I'm
aware looks so much nicer than that
black and white photo that piers
literally is giving me night that photo
has given me nightmares what you guys
doing we were talking about good so my
big thing is that I think that the
creative scope can be even bigger than
we've been anticipating I think we
haven't yet talked about very very nice
but we are basically trying to set
ourselves up for a third pillar with
craters that's the entire conversation
just so everybody knows the entire
conversation is to get as much whatever
I get let's say was right and let's say
it ends up being my preference would be
that's billion in video production for
like basically if you really think about
it for us to pull off we what our
ambition is we just basically have to
move the market to believe that are
three minute and seven second are 19
second are four minute nine second are
one minute eight second videos on
Facebook or the alternative to tbz
hi this is for anyway it's a pleasure
really nice to meet you how are you I'm
good how are you good such a pleasure
he's off tonight in she was thinking
about being a marketing major so I said
no I should come in I'll show you what
it's like I've been to five other
companies my dad by far the best one
that would make sense
today oh she likes to get to so Sachi
after grand see now and she's a dead
this isn't this masked man their shock
annoys awesome twenty thousand twenty
years younger on average
[Music]
hey how are you doing on Tom Tommy real
pleasure man I just want to say hello so
I didn't think I was gonna be here
Lisa how are you I was in London and it
got here the jet stream get us a favor
so I think I'd say hello or thanks ya
good man hey how's it going my man so
how are you good to see you
this is I'm so pumped I'm not even sure
I might be just as excited as you guys
this is cool how are you my man real
pleasure
congratulations this is a big day like
you know obviously we came in kind of
like you already done with the draft
process I'm like this is really for me
this is the first one yeah I'm really
excited I'm really excited so um we feel
really on it feels it was crazy I don't
know if you've been thinking I was so
much thinking about that meeting today I
was like it's just so crazy I don't know
I feel very blessed and honored and
we're very humbled and I just I'm so
confident and what what value we're
gonna bring here and I know how
different we are and heck I think Jalen
might end up making more money post his
playing career giving public speeches of
being the first guy that signed with
this new form de manner thing like this
is we're really going to change it so
we're very humbled you guys trust us and
I just want to thank all three of you so
much good
I'm so excited I don't know if I this is
awesome I'm so thankful I'm so thankful
we just signed our first guy so pumped
I'm so pumped like it's such a big deal
and Iraq the pitches already told you
Pat Riley yeah do we need oh yeah yeah
something's on the table I know you
haven't to change it yes when the
Masters you get a green jacket yes I'm
trying to create something that's kind
of like iconic yep historical reference
to when you sign with inter sports yeah
by central banner sports I think cool
thing for Jo is that he'd be the first
one to do it good so I think honestly
maybe the base differentiator for us as
an agency is the concept of like we want
to break this industry we're gonna go
down or do different things and the real
way for us to do that is to help you do
that if our players don't break the mold
and break the industry break the
barriers they're not going to successful
will not be successful at what we write
on it is things that they have to
overcome and this is a little bit weird
but what I did here on this one was I
took direct verbatim scouting feedback
and I told we got great like great kid
second a fourth round but when you get
feedback its objective to things that
were said but he's dealing with injuries
and if it's your shoulder size is his
biggest issue I think you know that I'm
aware of that
so these are the things like imagine
Russell Wilson had this thing some says
too small to the quarterback in the
league right and then what we're gonna
do with this is you're going to shatter
it we're going to keep it we're going to
display it at the office and then we're
going to give it to you and your careers
over
hopefully 15 20 years from Network what
put the feedback for when yes well
you're in Scouts what about helping
where'd he think he thought about you
know we played with that we thought
about that too
Monica you I think they could add one
thing yeah you got a room your room
that's a good idea what I'm gonna show
that's a really good idea
wind up is a good luck right brayla note
great good yes
clean I'm pumped up that was fun right
you're coming Monday yeah my man look
cool
try a hat Jack the shape you feel you
feel cool to me today
we're not rooting for the Wolves tonight
don't forget that TV with that I see in
wanna hit me up in the morning okay well
okay I'll go again see what thank you
oh very good huh sounds good you on gay
seborrhea good are you oh well I need to
it's on the side it's actually the way
we go really good cut that was such a
high you know when you know your
birthing you just saved my life The Rock
feeling really good you know first of
all quick little walk to the garden
haven't done this yet so I'm excited
about that
oh dear uh clear that they're doing them
what is that like what are you pointing
at the guy who's turned into the
drilling look it's called a welding
welding that's what I was looking for
welding feeling great man super excited
about signing Jalen it's a great kid how
are you going to get Joe okay
everybody's in the building
she's sitting here trying to figure out
the [ __ ] I'm gonna do for dailyvee
tomorrow that used to do in Saturday
family time so gonna call this will make
you a little film it we gotta come up
with some ugh you have text tonight
d-roc go to my sister's tomorrow for
some early Hanukkah stuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you